m
le mur de berlin est tombé en 1989 la
ville partagée développe désormais unis
berlin l'ancien la nouvelle capitale au
centre de l'europe
les anciens liaisons ont été rétablies
ce sont plus de 3 millions d'habitants
qui font connaissance avec les nombreux
visiteurs
tous se retrouvent à la recherche de
pistes dans cette métropole aux mille
visages crispés
le petit arrondissement au coeur de la
ville est l'illustration claire des
chocs entre les extrêmes dans berline et
le théâtre et habitent des étudiants des
turcs et les berlinois gueule la cascade
existe dans le massif des géants et dans
le para de la victoire son point
culminant accueille le mémorial national
de chine qu'elle qui commémore les
guerres de libération des 18 et sion 13
1815 lacroix qui coiffe ce monument de
20 mètres dans son nom à la colline puis
à tout l'arrondissement avance cette
époque la colline porte le nom de
vignobles arrondi depuis le 16e siècle
la vignette est cultivé sur ces coteaux
cette culture c'est ça en 1740 au xxème
siècle dans les années 70 cette
tradition ray parues depuis ce vignoble
et le plus ce pont triennal de toute
l'allemagne
il produit actuellement environ 1000
bouteilles par an
et les mis en bouteilles conservées dans
les caves de gouvernement de hesse
mais il est impossible d'acheter sur
arbres vaches et les services uniquement
un des invités de ville triés sur le
volet les arrière-cours et leurs milieux
sont caractéristiques de berlin mais
ceci se fait de plus en plus rares une
des plus belles cours et streamé
strophes cardon dans la hawks traces
lorsqu'en flâne dans cet ensemble du
début du siècle
on se retrouve dans la paix l'époque
même la structure moderne ne détruit pas
l'harmonie générale une promenade dans
les impressionnants cimetière du melinda
devient également une expédition
passionnant dans le passé il repose là
dans des tombeaux aux riches ornements
ce qui écrivirent l'histoire ou à propos
desquels on écrivit bâtisseurs
légendaire inventeur de génie de
nombreux artistes
nous rencontrons aussi l'art dans la
nouvelle galerie nationale à deux pas de
la philharmonie et de la salle de
musique de chambre
la construction d'acier et de verre fut
conçu par miss fender ou le sous-sol
accueille des oeuvres des 19e et 20e
siècles l'orée des chaussées des
expositions d'artistes contemporains à
l'extérieur la sculpture 4/4 dans un car
de l'américain georges briquet décade ya
coulé dans le béton de l'artiste folk
postel déclenchèrent d'abord des remous
mais elles sont désormais tolérée dresse
toujours rataro place au milieu du
trafic et vrombit
l'art dans les lieux publics avec vue
sur l'église du souvenir ses sculptures
un emplacement marquant juste devant on
repasse en tas de cartes pépin
l'intérieur est impressionnant le centre
commercial avec plantes et jeux d'eau
propose de nombreux restaurants cafés
avec musique life un cabaret un hôtel et
environ 100 commerce avec 1,8 km de
devantures sur trois niveaux des
services de tous types 24 heures sur 24
autour de cette sculpture devant euros
passante à une ambiance internationale
du bernois appelle la sculpture sans
aucun respect boula occasion de loisirs
en plein centre ville au point de
rencontre des touristes attirés par
l'église du kaiser
construite en l'honneur de guillon
premier inauguré par guillaume 2 en 1895
elle a été bombardée en 1943 incluse
dans un bâtiment neuf
elle est un symbole de berlin le café 15
l'âge lui également d'une renommée
mondiale
la visite est obligatoire pour tous
flâneur sur le coût d'un
le couvre feu dame doit son nom aux
presses électeurs eu à rim 2 qui fait
établir ici au xvième siècle une piste
cavalière et le château de kunas valt
otto von bismarck ancien envoyé
prussiens à paris où les s'inspirer des
champs elysées transformés ce chemin de
ronde ont un grand boulevard
il se battit pendant dix ans pour que
cette zone soit mise en valeur qu'en
1882 fut fondé la société du scoop dos
d'âne
le coût d'un mais aujourd'hui
internationale la nuit le ku'damm
scintille d'une lumière d'une grande
séduction
baghla étaient déjà connus dans les
années 20 pour sa vie nocturne agitée
des bistrots en sous sol des salles
cafés bars en tenant linde et de vastes
café avec jardin était prisé aujourd'hui
les 10 mois sont moindres même dans les
cafés sur le rue les vrais berlinois se
trouve plus rarement sur le ku'damm le
soir ils préfèrent se retirer dans leur
café habituel
sur le ku'damm la vie nocture dure
jusqu'au matin et on propose pour tous
les goûts au flat out le choix parmi les
boîtes est énorme même la mode créé à
berlin
evel attention au plan international
le nouveau coeur de la ville bas à poste
à ma place quarante ans après la guerre
un lieu series sur le terrain vague
situé entre l'est et l'ouest qui doit
renouer avec un passé glorieux une ville
du futur a été conçu sur une superficie
de 65 mille mètres carrés sont ni par
exemple qui a bâti une petite cité des
médias pour 1,5 milliard de dh marque
avec immeubles de bureaux cinéma est un
immense fourrure couvert
l'architecte italien renzo piano a été
chargé de la planification de l'ensemble
il créait des bouffes entre les gratte
ciel très inhabituel pour berlin qui
alternent avec des oasis de détente
renfermer des terrains y un mais la
poste à ma place c'est aussi ça un parc
de distraction avec un casino un théâtre
musical des restaurants des hôtels et un
cinéma multiplexe les arcades offre de
la place pour plus de son commerce
ils sont répartis sur trois niveaux de
ventes poissy la place du marchix de ce
nouveau centre
le bernina zoo est situé dans la partie
ouest de la ville le aux berlines attire
pack est situé près du schloss parc de
frédéric felder le zoo mérite bien
plusieurs superlatifs premier au
d'allemagne ouvert en 1844 il compte
aujourd'hui parmi les plus modernes et
importants du monde un spectacle proche
de ceux d'une foi est devenue un parc
animalier unique
ce sont quatorze mille animaux de 2000
espèces différentes qui y vivent
les visiteurs sont nombreux cardozo
possède un grand avantage
il est situé en plein centre de la ville
la gamme du même nom et gares de transit
vers varsovie et moscou ou terminus pour
de nombreux visiteurs
l'espagne passe toutes les minutes ces
trains relient les quartiers
périphériques au centre et contribuer
avec les métros à alléger le trafic dans
le centre de telles images sont rares
car la vie bat son plein dans cette
métropole
que ce soit sur la place devant le
cinéma de soba l'ass ou bien à la ville
dabakh place avec sa gare de métro joyau
d'architecturé elle fut la première gare
de métro de la ville classée monument
historique
ce n'est important de transport est
située aux portes du cadet v il s'agit
d'un des plus grands temples du commerce
du continent le nom car phrases des
fesses et plus anciens mais il a des
relents de guerre froide
à l'époque la mairie de schoenberg
écrivez l'histoire construite en 1912
1914 elle abrite la cloche de la liberté
très symbolique
on ne saura jamais vraiment comment
l'ours est devenue le symbole de la
ville il apparaît en 12 118 pour la
première fois dont le sceau de la guilde
des fourrures eu notre mascotte et
depuis un pont saint pour la ville de
berlin
l'amour est modérée des berlinois pour
les animaux se concrétisa en 1950 avec
la création d'un cimetière pour animaux
à l'anc vite canaris tortue hamster
chats ou chiens les chers compagnons
trouve ici le repos éternel
après cette escapade dans le sud
tournons nous vers l'ouest de la ville
sur leur sol en dame un autre exemple
des contrastes la gare de la période
empire jouxte un immeuble moderne en
acier et en béton et en verre et non
loin de là la tour de la radio des
années 20 les berlinois à l'appel le
grand escogriffe et voici le terrain de
la foire et le centre international des
congrès on y trouve à l'entrée une
sculpture de jean époux stiggy hic
batana l'homme construit sa ville le
titre est au programme un complexe
ultramoderne une vraie ville dans la
ville et des mentions énorme 320 mètres
de long un espace de 800 mille mètres
cubes construit des techniques les plus
modernes ont leur prix coût total
presque un milliard de deutsch mark
au nom du centre des congrès il s'essaie
à la lisière n'en de goût navale se
trouve le stade olympique
il peut accueillir 76 mille spectateurs
cette arène fut construite en 1936 par
bernard maj pour la 11eme olympiades
elle demeure aujourd'hui le plus constat
d'allemagne
les buts de hertha bsc club de grande
tradition ils sont chaleureusement fêter
mais on y acclama pas uniquement des
événements sportifs
ces plaques commémoratives toki monde
aux ébats du stade dans l'aval bun toute
proche les rollings temps par exemple
dans l'air le temps qu'on avale signifie
la forêt verte
la tour de grenat waltz est un but de
promenade prisé dans ce parc protégé
elle fut érigée en 1897 pour le centième
anniversaire de guillaume premier la
plage de vin est parmi les plus grandes
d'europe offre aux baigneurs 500
fauteuils cabine et 18 cents chaises
longues les jours de grosse chaleur on y
compte jusqu'à trente mille personnes
les vapeurs et les bateaux de linde et
servent toutes les îles de la havel et
bien sûr l'île aux paons l'art chimiste
luan qu'on cueille et produisit le
précieux vers ruby avant qu
frédéric-guillaume de nos forces at il à
son amante son château il fut construit
en 1794 dans le style d'une ruine
romantique
plus tard frédéric guillaume iii fit
créé au paysagiste l'aîné un parc
anglais avec des chemins entrecroisées
sont au privé était peuplé d'animaux
exotiques pour fontanes set il était
toujours une île mystérieuse quelques
minutes en aval voilà la magie du parc
de glienicke conçu également par les
nécrons parc d'aventurés c'est par un
amas toujours différent et ses bâtiments
de style varié surprennent
les formes classiques et caractérise le
château avec sa fontaine aux lions
transformé par chine quelle harmonie
entre architecture et paysages faune de
l'ensemble une heure d'art de niveau
européen
le pont de glienicke e anciennes
frontières étaient utilisés par les
russes et les américains pour leurs
échanges d'espions en longe le château
de babelsberg mon défi lui aussi par
chine qu'elle pour arriver au bras
latéraux de la rivière les excursions en
bateau sur les lacs et les canaux sur la
vesle et lâche près dure plusieurs
heures berlin vue de son côté le plus
calme et et des lic lorsque les vapeurs
approche le débarcadère il reste le
souvenir des bâtiments du maître chine
qu'elle comme entre autres son pavillon
dans le parc du château de
charlottenburg le château de
charlottenburg fut commencée en 16 195
par yoann me ring et s'appelle ad'abord
allison bourg il était destiné à ce fait
charlotte épouse du prince électeur
frédéric iii
après ça m'aurait fait rebaptiser en
château de charlottenburg
un chef-d'oeuvre baroque se trouve dans
la cour d'honneur ont 16 198 andreas
luthe créait le monument aux grands prés
ses lecteurs son fils frédéric
après son sacre comme premier roi
d'allemagne charge à eauze en des fang
et d'une décoration fastueuse ses
successeurs frédéric legrand et freddie
guilloux deux chargeurs les bâtisseurs
nobel stuff et langres en ce2 poursuit
la construction un parc immense invite à
la flânerie derrière le château
le musée égyptien se trouve directement
en face du château son joyau le plus
connu est sans aucun doute le buste de
néfertiti la grâce des sculptures paint
en calcaire vaut déjà la visite
la collection montre l'évolution de
l'art dans l'egypte ancienne de 5000
avant jésus-christ jusqu'aux 300 après
jésus-christ ces objets de renommée
mondiale ne se trouve pas dans le musée
mais sur les étagères de l'atelier des
plâtres
celui ci relève de l'administration du
musée d'état des biens de la culture
prussienne
ils sont conservés environ 12000 moule
de relief et de sculptures qui
permettent des moulages en plâtre en
bronze en résine ou bien d'autres
matériaux
le plus souvent l'empreinte a été prise
directement sur l'original lorsqu'en
fabrique ici une oeuvre de michel ange
l'acheteur n'achète pas un faux une
réplique exacte de l'original
les plâtriers et les stucateur sont
chargés de ses fabrications
pendant la préparation du moule puis le
séchage du plâtre les princesses luizet
frédéric de prusse subissent les
dernières retouches
ensuite en libère le plâtre du moule
avec précaution puis on le poly la
dernière étape une peinture authentique
garantie que seuls des spécialistes pour
en distinguer la réplique de l'original
des oeuvres détruites depuis longtemps
auraient disparu à tout jamais s'il
n'existait plus et moules l'atelier de
moulage prend donc de plus en plus de
sens
un monument haut et auguste comme aucun
autre dans le pays
et comme aucun autre peuple en possède
ainsi inaugura ton avec faste la colonne
de la victoire
le jour de ses d'un elle fut d'abord 6
au rail stade depuis 1939 elle domine le
gros sa sterne visible de très loin
cette victoire doré rayonne encore de la
gloire où il élimine yens lui par contre
bien que tout proche est déjà recouvert
de verre de cris bismarck fondateur du
rail en uniforme de cuirassiers l'ancien
palais des congrès situé dans le nord
duty 4 est aussi célèbre symbole de
l'amitié américano allemande lui 30
cents fut construite en 1957 avec des
fonds américains dans le bassin avant se
trouve la sculpture bêta fly d'enée
moore
derrière le palais aujourd'hui la maison
des cultures du monde démarre des
circuits d'excursions dans berlin sur
place près un tiers environ de la
superficie totale est constitué des
espaces verts forêt et au berlin la
ville aux mille pan c'est bien plus que
venise n'en offrir
une traversée edilivre du centre ville
en bateau ou est ce possible
à berlin
dans l'ancien fort et dérives de lâche
près le théâtre actuel frédéric ii
utilise à la situation prédestiné pour
construire un château
il le fit construire en 1785 pour son
frère ferdinand et le baptisa à juste
titre bellevue ce château est
aujourd'hui la résidence officielle du
président de la république
l'âge prêt permet une vue imprenable sur
la nouvelle chancellerie
c'est là dans ce coup de lâche près
entre le château de bellevue le rail ce
tag que se trouve le nouveau quartier du
gouvernement
les politiciens et autres habitants de
tirs 4 apprécie la double qualité de ce
quartier il habite dans le centre et
leurs lieux de détente est à leur porte
c'est l'artiste paysagiste l'aîné qui
façonna cet immense parc les
conséquences fâcheuses de la deuxième
guerre mondiale sont presque invisibles
pendant l'été le tir 4 et le lieu de
détente en numéro 1 de berlin un havre
de paix en plein coeur d'une métropole
intense
l'ancien charlottenburg à chausser
traverse le tir gamme dans son milieu
rebaptisée rue du 17 juin en 1953 à
l'accueil le plus grand marché aux puces
et d'artisanat tous les samedis et les
dimanches et les différences temps si tu
rentres l'université technique et le zig
zag propose un chaos ce big arrêts et
certains trésors dissimulés
on y trouve de quoi satisfaire tous les
goûts des objets de toutes sortes
historique à gros textes et beaucoup de
kitsch
ce marché attire les touristes tout
autant que les berlinois
la diversité de l'offre peut prolonger
le visiteur dans l'ivresse des achats ou
assommé celui qui cherche le rail ce tag
se trouve à l'extrémité du tien cadre de
1894 1933 se réunissent et le parlement
de son bâtiment de pôle oil ou
l'empereur guillaume ii la plaie avec
mépris la singerie du reich son incendie
et la deuxième guerre mondiale ont
laissé en ruine après une rénovation de
600 millions par sir norman foster
il abrite le parlement allemand le
bâtiment est ornée d'une coupole de
verre de 40 m de large et 2 23 mètres de
haut
la moitié de l'ancien coupole mais
accessible toute l'année
cent ans plus tôt avait été construite
tout très la plus célèbre des 14 au port
de la ville existants autrefois la porte
de brandebourg symbole de partitions et
de réunification et ne cesse d'attirer
les visiteurs étrangers le croit dit
ridge de shadows of et détruit pendant
la guerre
grâce à l'atelier du moulage déjà évoqué
il a été possible d'en couler une
réplique en 1997 berlin retrouve avec
l'hôtel a dans son grand hôtel de
tradition sur le pari à plate l'histoire
de la deûle ans commença en 1907 il
devint en trois ans un des hôtels les
plus beaux et les plus luxueux du monde
entier la venue en aide un linden du but
sur le côté de la porte de brandebourg
le réveil du grand boulevard aucune rue
de berlin qui n'est plus été marquées
par l'histoire le grand prince électeur
passé déjà il y a trois cents ans ou les
tuer la cheval frédéric de la fait
aménager en avenue réprésentatif et on
file axes le plus important de la ville
en construisant des bâtiments fastueux
le vieux fritz et ron à nouveau à 14
mètres de haut
immense devant la bibliothèque nationale
pour les étudiants entre autres la
bibliothèque nationale allemande est une
mine presque inépuisable
elle compte plus de 5 millions de livres
d'incunables des autographes et aussi
des partitions de valeur par exemple la
9e symphonie de beethoven
ce bâtiment néo baroque fut construit
entre 1903 et 1914 allons maintenant aux
gendarmes a marre c'était la plus belle
place de berlin avant la dernière guerre
qui la détruisent y restaurer elle est
redevenue son compte est possible les
deux églises
les cathédrales françaises et allemandes
furent construites au début du xviiie
siècle le schauspielhaus autrefois
théâtre national fut reconstruit par
chine qu'elle apprenne à 110
parfaitement restauré devenue salle de
concert il resplendit à nouveau les
drames de schiller connurent ici des
mises en scène spectaculaires que ce
soit sous la direction de léopold gesner
au de gustave green keynes la place et
son ensemble harmonieux de bâtiments la
dégage encore cette époque qui rend la
ville unique
la cathédrale françaises abritent un
petit musée ego notes et le café de la
tour qui offre une vue merveilleuse et
de bon vin mais revenons sous les
tilleuls une petite pause à une des
nombreuses terrasses boire et être vu
impression d'un grand boulevard
l'endroit idéal pour collectionner les
impressions les plus diverses les petits
gens se contentent de peu les grands
sont attirés par leur porcelaine de
meissen
il est possible de se déplacer en rite
chasse par exemple jusqu'aux galeries
lafayette dans la friedrichstrasse la
rue s'est métamorphosée depuis la
réunification
un nouveau lieu de flânerie a été créé
en plein centre ville
la mise en scène de la mode et l'
architecture originale du français jean
nouvel
ne doivent en aucun cas manquer au
programme les galeries lafayette sont
mitoyennes au passage de friedrich stadt
reliés entre eux par une zone piétonne
souterraine des créateurs de renommée
mondiale font de la haute couture pour
dames et des articles de luxe pour
hommes
lorsque les gens s'attrouper devant la
neue var eux c'était l'heure l'heure
d'une relève de la garde
dans la tradition prussienne le bâtiment
construit par chine qu'elle en 1816
abrita d'abord la garde royale et plus
tard les victimes du fascisme et du
militarisme ce défilé au pas de l'oie
est désormais passé
la flamme éternelle s'est éteinte dans
la noria var elle a été remplacée par
une sculpture de qu'était kollwitz une
mère et son fils mort elle fait office
de lieu commémoratif centrale de la
république allemande
didier aux victimes des guerres et de la
violence
les soldats de l'armée populaire
nationale se diriger vers le bâtiment
dans venait la relève le tchèque raul le
plus ancien bâtiment dont adam lind n
est un des édifices baroques le plus
important du nord de l'allemagne
il fut commencée en 16 119 sous la
direction de johan ring ce bâtiment au
cours des siècles servi d'arsenal de
musée au trophée de musées d'armement et
de panthéon
le musée de l'histoire allemande y élu
domicile dans les années 50 il s'appelle
aujourd'hui le musée historique allemand
la plupart des cafés avec terrasses sont
situés là prix du schloss bruch comme le
café de l'arsenal ou en face le café de
l'opéra
après avoir bu au café on va le soir à
un attelage à six chevaux 1 mais nasri
dierick legrand en 1743 à l'inauguration
de die stadt opa par le chemin de sable
le roi de prusse avait deux ont plutôt
chargé le maître bâtisseur cno bellstorf
de construire ce bâtiment représentatif
il fut un des premiers théâtres ne
dépendant pas d'un château l'opéra brûla
entièrement un siècle plus tard et fut
construit par lang ends il fut
entièrement détruit par la dernière
guerre sa rénovation réussie fut fêtée
le 4 septembre 1955 avec les maîtres
chanteurs de wagner
le programme en est électrique
on peut aussi assister aussi bien à des
représentations moderne que bien sûr à
des mises en scène classique
à
à côté de l'opéra se dresse le bernin
pas les appelait autrefois crainte
principale est il forme avec l'arsenal
la fin du boulevard historique celui ci
conduit après le schloss bruch à
alexander platz et s'appelle alors carli
pêche strass demande s'affrontent même
sur le plan architectural la cathédrale
à gauche du pont à droite le palais de
la république
le château des rohan solène avait occupé
cet endroit depuis 14 143 le plus vieux
plans de berlin montre la ville vers 16
150 les deux villes berlin et cologne
s'unir en 13 107 puis se séparèrent à
nouveau pour se réunir définitivement en
il existe encore des restes du mur
d'enceinte datant du xiiie siècle
mais le château fut détruit on
construisit un palais à sa place
l'assemblée populaire de la rda et siégé
et le palais de la république devait
impressionné mais les citoyens de la rda
se montrèrent peu enthousiaste il
baptisèrent le colosse magasin de l'onp
dans nos coeurs les portes en sont
closes et les lumières définitivement
éteinte à cause de la présence d'amiante
les urbanistes n'ont pas encore décidé
c'est le château sera reconstruit aussi
un bâtiment entièrement nouveau sera
érigée lors des festivités nocturnes de
la réunification sur la place max angel
le palais n'avait plus qu'un rôle de
décor
au sud s s'élève l'ancien conseil d'état
de la rda depuis le balcon duquel carli
pêche proclama la libre république en
le bâtiment fait aujourd'hui office de
chancellerie fédérale
sur l'autre rive de lâche près le
nouveau ministère des affaires
étrangères la cathédrale elle est encore
debout
les dégâts provoqués par la dernière
guerre ont été éliminés cet édifice
willem mignien dans le style de la
renaissance italienne a retrouvé son
aspect du début du siècle époque de sa
construction
au nord de la cathédrale entre deux bras
de lâche près un complexe de musées
importants qui porte le nom d'îles au
musée l'ancien musée chef-d'oeuvre
classique de charles frédéric chine
qu'elle fut le premier musée de prusse
il accueille le cabinet des estampes et
une collection de dessins devant
l'entrée la plus grande coupe en granit
jamais sculptés dans la pierre
le bâtiment derrière le musée était
ainsi à l'origine il s'agit de la
galerie nationale qui est érigée sur un
socle en hauteur ressemble à un temple
convainc siens avec son escalier
extérieur très large
construite entre 1866 et 1876 elle
devait servir de salle des fêtes
puis elle fut aménagé en musée d'art
contemporain on y expose désormais
surtout des peintures et des sculptures
de la fin du xviiie jusqu'au xxème
siècle qui conservent tout leur intérêt
pour les études de nus
alexandra calandre elle y est l'auteur
de la statue en bronze représentant le
roi frédéric guillaume iv à cheval
l'ancienne galerie nationale et les
autres bâtiments de l'île aux musées
doivent être rénovés régulièrement les
effets de la guerre ne sont pas les
seuls à avoir laissé des traces
l'eau de lâche près attaquent
constamment les vieux murs
le espagne qui traverse l'île à grand
fracas ce coup sans cesse des fondations
le musée de pergame est au centre de
l'île son attraction principale et
l'hôtel de bergame reconstruite au coeur
du musée
ce chef d'oeuvre et ligny stick fut
construit entre 180 et 160 avant
jésus-christ en hommage à the c'est
athéna déesse protectrice de pergame
plus de 100 personnages plus grands que
nature représentent des scènes
dramatiques le combat des dieux contre
les géants
d'une longueur de 120 m il s'agit du
plus long bas relief de la grèce antique
parvenus jusqu'à nous il recouvrait tout
le socle de l'hôtel à l'exception de
l'escalier extérieur à la pointe de
l'île aux musées se trouve le bâtiment
néo baroque du musée bode il fut
inauguré en 1904 sous le nom de musée de
l'empereur frédéric mais fut rebaptisé
en 1956 en l'honneur de son fondateur
wilhelm von bloodt qui avait rendu de
grands services en tant que directeur
des musées de berlin pendant de longues
années
ce bâtiment abrite une collection de
sculptures une galerie de peinture une
collection byzantine des débuts du
christianisme un cabinet de médailles et
la collection égyptienne
cette dernière contient des membres de
la famille pharaonique du roi akhenaton
à la reine néfertiti
presque tous ces bâtiments étaient en
ruines après la première guerre mondiale
certains furent définitivement gommer du
paysage
la destruction des ruelles du centre du
vieux berlin est et épouvantable dans le
quartier nicolaï en rang construisit le
plus vieux bâtiment sacré de la ville
l'église nicolaï construite autour de 12
tout le quartier fut reconstruit avec
ses innombrables petites ruelles avec un
grand amour du détail les façades les
pignons bas encorbellement et enseigne
en fer forgé sont conformes à la réalité
historique
les restes authentique ont été complétés
par du préfabriqué une petite ville
idyllique en plein centre de la
métropole
dans la vase en strass à proximité du
tribunal communal il y à un bâtiment
dans son état original de 721 le plus
vieux café de berlin bien nommé sol est
son instance réconfortait autrefois les
personnes affaiblies par les procès est
aujourd'hui les notabilités et les
touristes qui n'apprécient pas la
cuisine lourde à une bonne adresse à
disposition sur le maire kesha pouf à
l'ancienne maison de maître des
industriels du tabac et remet la se
trouvait à l'origine dans la bright
strass un des grands boulevards de
berlin on la démolit et on la rend
construite ici cet édifice baroque à
l'intérieur rococo propose des plaisirs
affiné dans plusieurs salles de
restauration à l'ambiance feutrée
rennes est celle n'y seraient pas entrés
pour se livrer à ses études de milieu il
caricature et la vie simple et des cafés
bon marché des arrière cours sambre son
monument est un peu à l'écart
contrairement à cette sculpture
monumentale
la fontaine de neptune se trouve dans la
chambre d'à roche traces entre l'église
sainte marie et la mairie le dieu des
mers est entouré de sa cour et de quatre
personnages féminins représentant le
rhin l'elbe lauder et lava excellent en
1888 la ville offrit cette fontaine 1
l'empereur guillaume ii que reynolds aig
a fini en 1891 à l'origine la fontaine
avait été installé devant le château
et c'est seulement en 1969 qu'elle
trouve à son emplacement actuel
la mairie de berlin ap les mairies rouge
à cause de sa façade en briques rappelle
un palais italiens de la renaissance
il a été construit en 1861 1870 parvez a
man à l'endroit où se trouvait déjà la
mairie moyen âgeuse à la hauteur du
premier étage le bâtiment présente une
frise la chronique de berlin
l'église sainte-marie église gothique
située directement en face est un des
édifices les plus anciens de la ville de
nombreux visiteurs de l'ouest et de
l'est
à nîmes le large cercle qui est
l'alexanderplatz les paysans des
quartiers extérieurs de la ville offrent
leurs marchandises sur les marchés
hebdomadaires
la place porte ce nom depuis la visite
du tsar alexandre 1er en 1805 l'ex
marché aux bestiaux et champ d'exercice
et faciles à localiser la tour de la
télévision avec ses 365 mètres indique
le chemin
lagarde alexandre da place en verre et
d'une grande élégance fut inauguré en
1882 par l'empereur guillaume premier
lui-même
l'événement était d'importance le
premier espagne fut lancée et les
berlinois moderne était fort fier de ce
moment de transport de beaulieu le plus
rapide du monde
le premier métro souterrain et aériens
suivi 20 ans plus tard tous les
quartiers importants de la ville sont
aujourd'hui relié par le rail
qu'empruntent aussi régulièrement les
trains des grandes lignes
l'alexandre platz se poursuit à l'est de
la gare
au premier coup d'oeil
l'alex comme on l'appelle est presque
trop étendue la vie n'occupe cette
immense place qu avec hésitation la
cohue bigarrée qui se pressent aux
échoppes animent la place qui est dominé
par une horloge universelle visible de
loin le nom du tout à fait augmenter le
chiffre d'affaires dans la gastronomie
et tout particulièrement en ce qui
concerne la cour et voit son succès
mondial partie de barlin elle vit le
jour dans la partie ouest de la ville
sur la stuttgart plate réel tard wade
1948 créa la première cour et vous du
monde
les internationaux de la cour est rousse
se rencontre plus tôt après cela roberg
le snack de valtra otsi forgues est une
île au milieu de la circulation
elle reprit il y à de nombreuses années
le grill grill colloque est le même dans
le respect de la tradition
c'est que rivaux ont la meilleure
réputation elle son travail à la main
est assaisonné avec raffinement
malgré la concurrence du kebab et du
hamburger le succès de la currywurst
berlinoise ne faiblit pas
revenons de prince albert dans le centre
ville près de la gare ferait des extras
le théâtre sur le chiffre par adam
c'était sic eu lieu la première de
l'opéra de quat'sous de brecht en 1928
ce théâtre de 20 après 1954 le lieu de
représentation de berlines ensemble que
brest et hélène weigl avait fondé
la maison de brest dans la chaussée et
strass jouxte le cimetière
dorothée teen spirit of ces deux grands
personnages du théâtre allemand ayant
trouvé le repos éternel
tout comme un certain nombre d'autres
personnalités
chaque soir dans la friedrichstrasse se
remplit la grande salle du frédéric
stadt palace qui compte près de 2000
places
m
idestyle le show intime comme ans plus
tard ce théâtre de variétés le plus
moderne et le plus important d'europe
est alors traversé par un souffle de
glamour comme autrefois
à quelques pas le pont van dama sûr
lâche près c'est sous ses ailes de
l'aigle prussiens que theodor fontane se
fiance à avec emilie gwan est
l'ancien et le nouveau se côtoient sans
cesse à berlin la ville à de nombreux
visages en trouvant plus d'une
architecture moderne de nombreuses et
des fils du baroque du classicisme et de
l'époque wilhelmy nien le musée
d'histoire naturelle est lui aussi resté
intact depuis 1889 dans l'ain validé ni
trace il est rattaché à l'université en
bold et compte parmi les meilleurs du
monde dans sa catégorie
la collection aux logiques exposé compte
20 millions d'objets les attractions
principales en sont le plus ancien
oiseau connu archéoptéryx dont il ne
reste que cinq exemplaires fossilisés et
le squelette landes 23 m et haut de 12
mètres d'un sauriens géant
la plupart des squelettes viennent de
l'est de l'afrique
mais pas cet objet il s'agit d'un
squelette provenant du musée du chien de
berlines blankenburg vingt mille objets
exposés dans cette salle le chien le
plus grand et le chien le plus petit des
quadrupèdes en porcelaine ou bien en
savant de vieilles photos de chiens
arbre généalogique médaille carnet les
vitrines d'exposition déborde d'objets
ceux ci se trouvent aussi dans ce musée
une attestation d'examen concernant un
teckel n'oublions pas une section qui
concerne les chiens en peluche si ce
musée du nom s de berlin est encore un
tuyau secret une autre curiosité de
l'autre côté de la ville est connue dans
le monde entier
le château son souci à potsdam
comme du temps de sa splendeur les
célébrités s'y voit à nouveau les
visiteurs de tous les pays se
rencontrent sur la terrasse de frédéric
legrand sans souci le roi de prusse
francophile souhaitait y vivent à son
souci est en paix et 10 qui salue même
le château de ses rêves que le maître
guy york 26 la hausse
fang mobile store réalisa entre 1745 et
10 747
il est situé dans un parc de 280
hectares qui conduit au bâtiment rococo
par-ci terrasse dans le style français
les jardins offre des vues variées sur
les sculptures en marbre
le nouveau palais avec les grottes et la
galerie de marbre l'orangerie une maison
de thé chinoise la colline de ruines la
maison du dragon le temple antique les
bains romains et d'autres bâtiments
construits au goût des époques
à
invité par le monde a cru le philosophe
français voltaire demeura ici 3 ans et
puisant son inspiration dans le parc
dans des longues discussions et dans des
cancers de flûte
lorsque fritz mourut atteints de goutte
le 17 août 1786 il ne se doutait pas que
berlin vivait une deuxième renaissance
après 200 bandes année
m
à